hey 42 here do you ever hear a noise not
a bump in the night per se but a halt a
mysterious constant and very
low-frequency noise if so you may be one
of an estimated 2% of the global
population that can hear the whole the
hum is the name given to an ominous and
very mysterious deep rumbling noise that
can reportedly be heard by thousands of
individuals across the globe it
apparently sounds like a very
low-pitched rumbling sound kind of like
a diesel engine truck idling in the
distance but no matter how hard people
search no one has been able to locate
the source of the sound it sounds like
it's coming from all directions equally
some say it even comes from the sky this
is a recording of the home made in Taos
New Mexico
for some the home causes headaches and
nosebleeds it drives off as completely
insane with at least one suicide being
attributed to the hob it's usually heard
in specific towns around the globe for
several months or years before it
disappears and for some people it never
goes away the first documented
occurrence of the home was in Bristol in
the UK in the 1970s a local newspaper
asked Bristol City residents have you
heard the whole and over 800 people said
they had since then resident from
hundreds of towns and cities who all
over the world have reported hearing the
horn and always describe the sound in a
similar manner some of the more notable
locations where up to 12% of the
population have heard the noise are Taos
New Mexico logs in Scotland and Auckland
New Zealand report of the home have
become so great that a website has been
created where people can report their
experience with the home and you can
view a map of all of the reported cases
across the world the home has even been
linked to terrorism in 2013 aaron alexis
shot and killed 12 innocent people at
the washington d-c Navy Yard police
later found the following message on his
computer ultra-low-frequency attack is
what I've been subjected to for the last
three months and to be perfectly honest
that is what has driven me to this this
and other evidence led conspiracy
theorists to conclude that the home is a
government attack or experiment being
used on citizens to alter their state of
mind they believe the government
generated a home using satellites whilst
others say the HAARP project in Alaska
is to blame but Illuminati and Lizard
Men aside has science been able to find
a reason for the home what is the cause
have animals learn how to hum and are
playing a gigantic practical joke on us
puny humans is god bored or is it just
tinnitus the home is most commonly heard
by people aged between 55 and 70 so one
instantly thinks it's the medical
condition tinnitus you know how your
granny is always complaining about a
noise that isn't actually there except
for that one time you turned her hearing
aid up to maximum that was pretty bad of
you but if the cause is tinnitus it
shouldn't the spread of people who
reported hearing the hum be evenly
distributed across the globe after all
tinnitus doesn't favor certain regions
but the home is usually reported by
clusters of people around specific
locations also new research carried out
recently in Cambridge England suggests
that the source of the home is external
not internal which is what home
sufferers have always argued people have
also blamed the following things for
causing the home traffic local factories
and heavy machinery leaking pipes phone
masts wind farms submarine communication
systems UFOs and even mating fish
hundreds of Southampton residents who
could hear the horn we're told it was
being caused by a school of mating
Midshipmen fish if you make this eerie
sound to try to attract a female
okay that single incident with the horny
fish could have been a genuine cause of
the home but the other potential causes
have mostly been disproven however new
research has suggested that microseismic
activity from ocean waves impacting the
sea bed causes our planet itself to
vibrate in certain areas around the
globe closing a low-frequency droning
sound researchers say that this sound is
such a low frequency that only a small
percentage of the population would be
able to hear it
this ocean based answer also explains
why the home is more commonly heard in
coastal towns so for some this answer
has finally settled their lifelong quest
to locate the source of their annoying
air penetrating friend but forever home
sufferers who disbelieve this
explanation their search continues
thanks for watching you'll probably pass
by anything nothing more about it but
this is the smallest town in all of
America with a grand population of just
one there are hidden oil wells all over
Los Angeles these secret oil wells are
hidden right in plain sight somewhere
next to schools and shopping malls